[Music]
uh ms pacman's nipple
no that's brown why would you know that
to be
or not to be not to be thank you
joan of arc rod stewart martha stewart
he-man master of the universe
i got it gay robin hood
[Music]
what are you doing you want me liven
things up or not of course i do
all right then relax you turn off all
the lights that don't have colored bulbs
all right joe take the pigs in the
blanket and put them to sleep it's time
to get wife
get this furniture out of here y'all
we're making a dance floor
come on y'all put the turkey wraps down
we're about to get wild
please do that thing do that thing
[Music]
one more time one more time
[Music]
you left the address in the telephone
number right i'm gonna leave it on the
table
okay don't mess up my coat boy even
though i didn't know the phone number
i was just going to the party a few
blocks away as long as i came back on
time
i didn't have anything to worry about
now this is what i'm talking about i
waited 13 years to get to my first party
and now i'm here let's get this party
started i mean i can't believe i'm
saying this but sandra's the only other
grown-up here
actually i am dressed up i'm you
um what shut up sandra shut up sandra
oh my god that's so cool you're gonna be
twinsies no we're not
wait you guys should stand together all
day i'm up for it
yeah i'm gonna find a costume to put on
so let's keep an eye out for teens
tweens people who look inappropriately
large or small
are you guys even listening to me
hello nothing yeah got it
everybody say cavities
frankenstein
hungry
children
come on dad every year the same thing
your bolts are rusty
wow give me back the candy i need them
it's for the children please come on i
don't have enough candy
i don't have enough candy
you think that's so different from who
you really are
doctor make bad bride frankenstein sue
doctor
hello everyone and a happy all hallows
eve
guess who i am cliff clavin
well coach let me give you a hint i
went to florida to find the fountain of
youth cliff clavin
i'll coach you i'm constantly young well
i think your ears are too big
well for ponce leon no for you cliffy
well i don't know coach i happen to be
very proud of my big ears
i mean a lot of women consider them
erogenous zones during uh
heavy petting
donna blue shirt
badge night stick you
are a policewoman yep you're a regular
sherlock holmes
i solved that mystery before you did
okay this is fun andy
you are ufc legend chuck liddell that's
right
girl from the ring to me sherlock holmes
is
literally the greatest character in the
western canon
smart intuitive handsome replaces pasty
british frailty with superhuman physical
fitness and you get
sherlock traeger
so what do you guys think
[Music]
okay ernie likes it george what do you
think
and careful if i don't like your answer
i'll have to cuff you
and take you downtown
yeah that's fine fine
i've been at the gym every day for three
months to fit into this and it's just
fine
hey i did the crime make me do the time
i got it you like it ernie george
what's the matter my mom's treating me
like crap
i'm sorry honey but your mom always
treats you like crap why are you letting
it get to you
cause this is different she's doing
stuff to me she did when i was a kid
if it bothers you that much you should
talk to her
no forget it that's not gonna make it
worse benny we need to talk
what did i just say why do you always
have to get involved because she took a
note to protect and serve
she's one of la's finest
[Laughter]
this is gonna be so good we're young and
we're funny that's us we party that's me
and joe
i don't know which side is what
come set me up
[Music]
oh my god are you really gonna go out
like this
does it look ridiculous just exactly
what you want to do tonight
i'm putting on this sexy ass hot cat
outfit
i'm turning you on can you turn me on i
have to look at you in a dress all night
really what is this
oh my god is that the front
yeah you're really a jersey chick now
babe
how does he look you look like your
sister
you sure you don't want to put lipstick
on
he thinks he looks so hot even in a
dress and you know what he
is his muscles were all showing he looks
hot but i'm just not attracted to a guy
in a dress just
it's not for me i look better than you
as a woman i can't look at you
mr potato head that's right
hey where's my lovely daughter tonight
she's at home i knew that you would be
here and i was worried that you might be
concerned seeing us together at night
you're a very thoughtful guy but really
i have
no problem with the two of you dating
really i mean
look at you you just you know beautiful
you're beautiful
oh on the inside where your spirit lives
listen tell her come to the party and i
don't mind at all good i'll text her
[Music]
okay you can text without looking at
your phone i think it's rude not to
maintain eye contact with people that
i'm talking to
that's for me wow that's amazing
high five charles
seriously no costume what the hell
charles where's your halloween spirit
but you guys always make fun of me i
have
never once insulted you in my life
especially vis-a-vis your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person and or thing yes i do remember
sir permission to sprint to my car and
get my emergency costume does it matter
if i say no
bam bam boom
what the what why are you dressed up you
look like an idiot but
yeah what are you supposed to be a sassy
car mechanic no
come on he's clearly the rejected
pop-tarts mascot harry pop-tart
i am not you know who i am squad that's
enough
you're making boyle for bat on purpose
he's elvis yes elvis stoico the canadian
figure skater no
you